Guten Tag, mein Name ist Bulur. Ich bin die Diensthaberin der Ärztin auf der Station und würde gerne das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen. Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, das ist in Ordnung für alle.
Ok, so als werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen, dann direkt Ihrer aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen. Und wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Maria, mein Nachname ist Freudenberg.
Freudenberg, könnten Sie Ihren Vornamen bestablieren?
Maria M-A-R-I-A und Freudenberg F-R-E-U-D-E-N Berg.
Freudenberg, wie alt sind Sie?
65, Frau Doktor.
65, ok. Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
1. Juni 1960.
Ok, wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ja, ich bin 1,80 Meter.
1,80 Meter, ok. Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
92.
92, ok. Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausarztin?
Herr Föller.
F-E-U.
Ja.
F-E-U-L-L-E-R.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Ok, vielen Dank. Und was für Sie heute so? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, Frau Doktor, habe ich Bauchschmerzen.
Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, Bauchschmerzen, deswegen.
Könnten Sie sagen, wo genau Ihre Schmerzen sind?
Ja, mittel und ober Bauch, ich kann sagen.
Mitteln und ober Bauch. Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Seit drei Monaten habe ich Schmerzen und ich fühle mich sehr unruhig.
Unruhig?
Ja, und abgeschlagen. Ich fühle mich immer müde.
Zuerst, vor drei Monaten, war meine Schmerzen nicht schlimm.
Dann im Verlauf verschlechtert.
Aber seit drei Wochen ist meine Schmerzen besser als vor zwei Monaten.
Aber meine Müdigkeit im Verlauf der Zeit immer verschlechtert.
Ich fühle mich sehr müde und verschöpft.
Sie meinen, Ihre Schmerzen langsam aufgetreten.
Ja.
Ihre Schmerzen sind langsam aufgetreten.
Aber mit der Zeit ist es besser geworden.
Schmerzen ist besser, aber meine Müdigkeit und ich fühle mich sehr müde.
Ich habe keine Lust, etwas zu machen.
Deswegen komme ich Ihnen.
Ok. Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie jetzt Schmerzen?
Ja, ich habe Schmerzen, aber nicht schlimm.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von ein bis zehn?
Wobei ein sehr leichter, sehr starker Schmerzen entspricht?
Vielleicht vier oder drei manchmal.
Vor zwei Monaten war es vielleicht sechs oder sieben, aber jetzt vier oder drei.
Strahlen Sie Schmerzen irgendwo raus?
Ja, nur im Bauch.
Ok, nur im Bauch.
Fühlen Sie sich ein Druckgefühl im Oberbauch?
Ja, ich fühle ein Druckgefühl.
Ich fühle, mein Bauch ist dick geworden.
Und ich habe Hunger.
Ist dieser Druckgefühl im linken oder rechten oder ganzen Bein?
Haben Sie einen Unterschied?
Ich habe Bauchschmerzen, nicht Bein.
Ich verstehe. Aber haben Sie gesagt, Sie haben ein Druckgefühl?
Im Bauch.
Welche Seite? Linken Seite oder rechten?
Mittel, manchmal rechts, manchmal mittel.
Aber mittel Seite.
Haben Sie auch Sodbrennen?
Nein, habe ich keine Sodbrennen.
Oder einen Sauerstoff?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ja, ich fühle mich manchmal Fieber. Aber ich habe keine Fieber denke ich.
Aber ich fühle mich warm, ich kann sagen.
Okay. Und haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Nachschweiß? Ja, ein oder zwei Mal hatte ich gehabt, aber jetzt habe ich nicht.
Okay. Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewöhnlich ab oder so genommen?
Ja, wann in letzter Zeit meinen Sie?
In sechs Monaten. Ja, in erheblichen sechs Monaten.
Vielleicht in einem Jahr hatte ich acht Kilo abgenommen.
Acht Kilo? Ja.
Okay. Abgenommen. Und ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Ja, selten, aber manchmal ist es schwindelig.
Könnten Sie diese Schwindelig beschreiben?
Ja, ich kann sie genau beschreiben, Frau Doktor.
Wenn Sie aufstechen oder ist diese Werte, wenn Sie aufstechen?
Ja, wenn ich aufstehe, manchmal fühle ich mich schwindelig.
Okay. Ist Ihnen übel?
Ja, ich habe auch Übelkeit seit drei Monaten.
Seit drei Monaten. Okay. Haben Sie Erbrechen?
Nein, hatte ich niemals. Nur Übelkeit?
Ja, ich hatte Übelkeit, aber keine Erbrochenen.
Okay. Denken Sie, es gibt eine bestimmte Auslöse für Ihre Schmerzen oder Ihre Beschwerden?
Zum Beispiel Ernährungsstil oder Bewegung oder Stress?
Nein, ich habe keine Auslöse. Ich weiß nicht.
Okay. Oder gibt es etwas für diese Schmerzen, das Sie verschlimmert oder verbessert?
Nein, aber heutzutage kann ich nicht genug laufen.
Wenn ich laufen, fühle ich mich müde. Wenn ich auf der Strecke steige, fühle ich mich müde und abgeschlagen.
Beim Arbeiten kann ich nicht gut konzentrieren.
Besonders in den letzten drei Wochen habe ich auch Konzentrationsstörungen.
Okay. Haben Sie Brustschmerzen? Nein, keine.
Okay. Haben Sie Hüsten?
Hüsten habe ich nicht. Keine Hüsten.
Atemnot?
Ich fühle mich manchmal mit Atemnot. Mein Herz schlägt manchmal mehr als gewöhnlich.
Wenn ich besonders auf der Strecke steige, fühle ich meinen Herz schlägen.
Ich fühle mich müde. Ich muss nach einem Stock warten. Wir wohnen im zweiten Stock.
Ich muss drei Minuten warten, dann gehe ich weiter. Ich fühle mich sehr müde, wenn ich besonders auf der Strecke steige.
Okay. Haben Sie eine Schwellung oder eine Rötung in Ihren Beinen?
Ja, meine beiden Beine sind dick geworden. Die letzten zwei Monate.
Ich fühle Kriben in meinen Beinen. Wie am Eiser laufen.
Okay. Haben Sie ein Taubhausgefühl oder Misserfindigkeit?
Ja, ich fühle ein Amäisegefühl. Das ist Misserfindigkeit, oder?
Ja. Ich denke. Haben Sie Kriben auch?
Ja.
Meine Hand ist auch rot geworden. Meine Hand. Beide Hände sind rot geworden.
Händeflache. Beide Händeflache sind rot geworden. Ich weiß nicht ob das...
Okay. Haben Sie andere Hautveränderungen?
Ich habe zum Beispiel mit den Augen Haut oder auf den Bauch anderen Blauen...
Lecker.
... Haut, besonders Bauchhaut, hatte ich Rotfläche bemerkt.
Frau Doktor, ich habe vergessen zu sagen, vor drei oder vier Monaten war ich zwei Wochen gelb geworden.
Aber jetzt bin ich nicht gelb.
Vor drei oder vier Wochen?
Ja. Monat. Oder ich erinnere mich, ich bin zwei Monate gelb geworden.
Okay. Gelb geworden.
Zwei Wochen lang gelb geworden, dann bin ich jetzt nicht gelb.
Okay. Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlösen oder Stuhlgang?
Ja, ich habe chronische Verstöpfung und jetzt seit drei Monaten gehe ich oft, besonders nachts, im Klo zum Wasserlösen.
Okay. Aber es gibt eine Veränderung.
Haben Sie zum Beispiel Hautveränderungen oder Konsistenz aufgefallen?
Ja, ich weiß nicht Frau Doktor, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Okay, kein Problem.
Haben Sie oder ist bei Ihnen eine chronische Erkrankung bekannt?
Ja, einmal hatte ich eine Leberentzündung vor 15 Jahren.
Frau Doktor, das ist eine lange Geschichte, das hat keine Verbindung denke ich.
Und zwei Wochen wurde ich stationär behandelt und hatte eine unklar Bauchspeichel, eine drüse Entzündung oder Krankheit.
Unklar, wie in dieser Zeit?
Ja, gleichzeitig. Bauchspeichel, drüse Entzündung und Leberentzündung hatte ich gehabt.
Und vor zehn Jahren wegen Unterschenkelfraktur wurde ich operiert.
Unterschenkelfraktur?
Unterschenkelfraktur.
Unterschenkel, okay, Entschuldigung.
Haben Sie noch etwas über Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, ich bin ganz gesund Frau Doktor, ich habe keine anderen Probleme.
Okay, sehr, sehr gut. Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, wegen Schmerzen nehme ich ab und zu Ibuprofen.
Welche Dosierung?
Ja, ich erinnere mich, 600 mg vielleicht.
Und manchmal hatte ich Magenschmerzen, deswegen nehme ich Omeprazole, wenn ich saure esse oder wenn ich Magenschmerzen habe.
Okay, bleibe da. Ja.
Noch etwas?
Nein, kein. Kein mehr Frau Doktor.
Okay, würden Sie schon einmal operiert, bis auf diese Frakturoperation?
Nur einmal operiert.
Okay, Frau Denberg, rauen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche 10 Zigaretten pro Tag.
10 Zigaretten. Seit wann rauen Sie?
Ja, vielleicht 40 Jahre Frau Doktor, das ist noch lange her.
Okay.
Gefällt mir.
Ja, ich verstehe. Manchmal brauchen wir diese Substanz.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, natürlich trinke ich. Einen oder zwei Gläser Schnaps jeden Tag.
Ich trinke gerne.
Okay, Schnaps trinken Sie kleine oder große Gläser?
Ja, normale Gläser. Aber ich trinke auch 6 oder 7 Flaschen pro Woche.
7 Flaschen?
6 oder 7, ja.
Meine Arbeit ist sehr stressig Frau Doktor, deswegen fühle ich mich gut.
Okay, diese Flasche ist 1 Liter, 1,5 Liter oder 1 Liter?
1,5 Liter denke ich.
Okay.
Und manchmal trinke ich Wein. Mit meinen Freunden, nur Freunde an Bocheln.
Wie bitte?
Wein, ich trinke Wein am Wochenende.
Okay, hatten Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, niemals. Ich bin ganz gesund.
Ja, das ist sehr gut. Und haben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja Frau Doktor, ich kann nicht Sport treiben. Ich habe keine Zeit.
Okay, gibt es in Ihrer Familie irgendwelche grundlegenden Erkrankungen?
Mein Vater ist leider an Gedachnisschrumpf verstorben.
Okay.
Und meine Mutter leider an Bluthochdruck und Zuckerkrankheit.
Zuckerkrankheit, okay.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich bin ein Kind.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich arbeite im Straßenbau.
Straßenbau?
Ja.
Machen Sie?
Wir bauen Straßen.
Straßen, okay. Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Nein, ich bin geschieden Frau Doktor.
Geschieden, ja.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Dann sind Sie gesund?
Ja, sie sind Gott sei Dank gesund.
Okay. Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich erinnere mich nicht Frau Doktor. Als ich Kind war, habe ich Impfung gehabt, aber ich weiß nicht.
Okay. Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, nein. Ich nehme in Deutschland.
Okay. Frau Freudenberg, ich habe keine weiteren Fragen. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder Fragen haben Sie?
Ja, Frau Doktor, ich habe Angst. Ich habe seit drei Monaten Bauchschmerzen. Ich habe keine Lust etwas zu machen. Was kann ich haben? Was vermuten Sie?
Frau Freudenberg, ich verstehe Sie und Sie möchten wissen, was Sie haben. Aber es ist sehr früh etwas Geniales zu sagen.
Ihre Beschwerden können viele Ursachen haben. Deshalb kann ich Ihnen leider noch keine Antwort geben.
Zuerst müssen wir ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen, um eine eindeutige Diagnose zu stellen.
Wenn die Ergebnisse vorliegen, kann ich Ihnen genau was sagen. Bitte machen Sie sich keine Sorgen. Und bitte denken, positiv zu denken.
Okay, Frau Doktor.
Ich fühle mich besser jetzt. Ich denke, Frau Doktor. Vielen Dank.
Sie sind in guter Hand.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ist es möglich oder?
Ja, natürlich. Bitte schön.
Haben Sie eine Allergie oder?
Ja, Allergie.
Ja, ich habe keine Allergie. Ich bin ganz gesund.
Okay.
Noch etwas? Okay, ich werde aber jetzt ...
Schlafstimmung, dann können wir auch fragen.
Nee, uja.
Ja, ich habe Keilnuss zu essen, Frau Doktor. Besonders seit zwei Monaten. Ich möchte nicht essen.
Und? Schlafen Sie gut? Nein.
Nein, nein, ich kann nicht gut schlafen.
Okay.
Ich habe ein bisschen Alergie.
Und? Schlafen Sie gut? Nein.
Nein, nein, ich kann nicht gut schlafen.
Ich habe sehr viel Stress, Frau Doktor. Deswegen schlafe ich nicht gut.
Haben Sie Einschlafprobleme oder Durchschlafprobleme?
Ja, beide, ich kann sagen.
Beim Einschlafen habe ich Probleme. Ich kann mindestens in einer oder zwei Stunden schlafen.
Aber beim Durchschlafen muss ich aufwachen, so was auch immer. Deshalb habe ich Schlafstörer.
Okay.
Lup kidna acces?
Ja ein bisschen hearts.
Okay.
und 92 kg schwer. Frau Freidenberg stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit drei Monaten
im linken Saal perublikär und epigastrischer Bauchschmerzen sowie Fatigue.
Die Patienten berichteten, die Schmerzen sind langsam aufgetreten und im Mittelfeld schlimmer geworden sind.
Die Patienten klagten über Vertigo, Sodbrennen, Blechung, Vertigo, Druckgefühle im Bauch,
Flatulence, Neusea und Nachschweiß.
Darüber hinaus berichteten die Patienten, dass sie beide Beine Schwellung hatten.
Die Patienten hatten folgende Begleitsymptomen.
Konzentrationsstörungen, Obstipation und Nocturne, Insomnie und Apathense.
Der Patient erwähnt, der Patient erwarte, der Patient hat Müdigkeit, der Patient hat Fatigue.
Die Patienten hatten seit drei Monaten Fatigue, besonders bei Bewegungen wie Gehen oder Treppe steigen.
Die Patienten berichteten, sie hatten eine Hautveränderung im Ganzenbau wie Rote Flasche und beide Händenflasche.
Leiden die Patienten unter Fieber?
Der Patient hat gesagt, dass sie ein warmes Gefühl haben, aber die Fieber ist unklar.
Bei der Körperliereuntersuchung würde ich die Körpertemperatur messen.
Vor 15 Jahren berichteten die Patienten eine Leberentzündung und Bauchspacheldrüseentzündung.
Leberentzündung, Hepatitis.
Aber die Diagnose war nicht unklar.
Sie ist nicht unklar über Diagnose. Sie hat zwei Wochen im Krankenhaus bleiben und konservative behandelt.
Sie nimmt bei Bedarf Ibuprofen und Omeprazole ein.
Vor zehn Jahren wurde sie wegen einer unter Schenkelfraktur eine Operation durchgeführt.
Sie hat gesagt, dass ihr Vater an einem Seilmisch verstorben ist.
Ihre Mutter hat Arteriellaehypertonie und Diabetes Melotus Type 2. Sie ist ein Seilkind.
Sie braucht seit fünf Jahren Senzigareten pro Tag. Sie trinkt ein bis zwei Gläser Schnaps und sechs oder sieben Flaschen Bier jeden Tag.
Sie trinkt am Wochenende ein Glas Wein. Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Sie ist eine Sterbemauerin. Sie ist geschieden und hat zwei gesunde Kinder. Sie hat keine Allergen oder Unverträglichkeit.
Sie ist unbekannt und die Reise an Amnese unaufhängig.
Sie ist eine Sterbemauerin. Sie ist geschieden und hat zwei gesunde Kinder. Sie ist geschieden und hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Was kann man für eine Syrose für ein Symptom sprechen?
Es geht um ein Druckgefühl im Mittel- oder Rechtsbein.
Sie hat eine Konzentrationsstörung, eine Ödeme in den Beinen und hat außerdem Ikterus vorgeschrieben.
Es gibt Mühe, Bauchschmerzen, Druckgefühl im rechten Bauch, Druckgefühl im rechten Epigastrium und Konzentrationsstörung.
und Konzentrationsstörung und Ikterus vorgeschichte sprechen eine Labelsirose.
Okay und?
Der Patient hat viele Risikofaktoren wie Alkohol und Nikotinkonsum.
Okay, welche Differenzialdiagnose haben Sie denn?
Als Differenzialdiagnosen kommen Magenkarcinoma und Hepatitis auch.
Ob aber auch Schmerzen, Alkoholkonsum und Vorgeschichte auch.
Ja, eine Cholestitis oder Akutapancreatitis können wir denken.
Okay und was machen Sie um Ihre Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen?
Okay, zur Abklarung der Beschwerden sollten die folgenden Maßnahmen durchgeführt werden.
Zuerst würde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Dafür beobachte ich ob Hautveränderungen und Ödeme bei der Bahn sind.
Ich teste den ganzen Bauch ab.
Was erwarten Sie bei der Palpation?
Ich erwarte zuerst eine Hepatomegalin im rechten Seite.
Und ich erwarte eine Telenjectasie auf den Bauch.
Der Patient hat gesagt, er habe Palmarita und ich beobachte ob ich Theruss habe.
Okay, Sie haben schon die körperliche Untersuchung durchgeführt.
Was möchten Sie machen?
Ich würde Blut abnehmen und einige Laborarten durchführen.
Welche Laborarten würden Sie kontrollieren?
Ich würde ein großes Blutbild, Entzündungsparameter, Gerüntungsparameter, Lebe- und Nierenwerte und Hepatitis marken bestimmen lassen.
Dann würde ich eine Optomatsonographie durchführen und meine Verdachtstheorose bestätigen und die andere Möglichkeit ausschließen.
Dann würde ich ein CT veranlassen.
Dann würde ich die Verdachtstheorie bestätigen und die weitere Therapie vorlegen.
Ich würde zuerst die Patienten stationär aufnehmen und Vitalparameter kontrollieren.
Dann würde ich eine gastroenterologische Konzertsitzung durchführen.
Dann würde ich eine konservative oder symptomatische Therapie beginnen.
Ich denke, diese Patienten brauchen eine organische Transplantation.
Welche Risikofaktoren kennen Sie für Leberstirose?
Das ist die wichtigste Risikofaktor.
Der Patient hat viel Stress und hat eine Leberentzündung oder Bauchspeicheldrüseentzündung vorgeschlagen.
Diese sind Risikofaktoren für Leberstirose.
Wir haben nicht so viel Zeit.